congrats on the movie you guys are good
together
um isabella and i could be wrong about
this but i heard that you became good at
copying jason or embodying jason during
the shoot
and i'm wondering if you can tell the
secret of sort of copying him
it's all in the look by the way hi i
feel like i see you
everywhere i saw you recently for uh
like a few months ago actually yeah um
did jason what is it you just gotta make
your voice weird a little bit raspy
kind of like a little yeah because he
doesn't care it's just he's
so silky you gotta kind of squint your
eyes a little bit looking like you're
sleepy but
not like plastic surgery face lift it's
like sleepy so
and then it's like it's like um and it's
like
look through the eyebrows really raise
those eyebrows i don't know how but his
eyebrows are like raising to the head to
the head like i guess jason hasn't seen
this before
[Laughter]
so uh listen for the two of you i love
learning about the behind the scenes or
the making of a movie i love learning
stuff that people don't know
for each of you what do you think might
surprise people to learn about the
making of sweet girl
i mean to me it was one of the silliest
funnest times i've ever had i mean such
serious topics for tackling and i feel
like
it was the best production i've ever
been a part of i don't say that just
because we produced it but
truly it is i had everyone that i love
behind it um
we're all excited to be there and i
think her and i are pretty
and even addreno we're all real
goofballs and we have a lot of fun so
it's in all the seriousness
i feel like it was one of the best
experiences i've ever had on any set
oh i'm definitely gonna say the same um
a lot of these topics are really
personal to me in my real life like they
they apply almost uh
pretty directly so and so it was like
rough you would expect it to be rough
right you would expect to be a journey
emotional go to therapy after the movie
maybe perhaps
but because of the cast and because of
like who i was around and
um especially during that scene where we
were in the hospital
and the mother is dying the played by
adriana
who is an amazing person she'd never
seen herself in prosthetics
she'd never seen herself look so sick
and she was having a really hard time
i mean she's dying over and over again
in a scene and
my first instinct was to just make her
laugh that was it like i
i cannot i can't be one of those people
that's like always in character i've
seen because
that's how you lose yourself so my
technique in
doing dark movies like this is just have
some freaking fun
i am curious uh jason you really deliver
an emotional performance in that hallway
and i'm curious uh what it was like for
you going to that place
and filming that sequence because it's
like it's shot handheld
you're in a real location i'm sure you
can't do this ten times
and deliver that same emotion can you
sort of talk about filming that sequence
yeah it was tough because it wasn't
designed that way and uh
i pulled brian aside and uh i asked him
i said i'd like to
i'd like to walk away and kind of
blocked and walk through it
get to the elevator put some extras
right here walk this hallway have some
extras there
just kind of get to a quiet hallway he's
kind of trapped in this one space but it
just overtakes him
i think rooted down in all of it um
we did one take where the camera
actually hit because they're going
backwards
while they're in front of me and they
hit the wall and i can see it happening
so i can see them going into it it's
just like [ __ ] and they
you know just clobber this wall
sucks because you're fully in it and you
feel bad for everyone and
obviously they feel bad too because
you're in it
and um yeah you're right i mean it's
nice when you answer the question for me
you can't do it 10 times man
it's it's you only have so many and i i
also don't want to be in that pain you
know we try to get away from it so it's
it's
to do it real and living as is the first
time i've had to do that
it's looking at audrey on looking at um
isabella and you hire the people around
you that you really believe that are
gonna
lift you up and make your performance
better
um it's pretty easy because i just look
down at them and i love them both dearly
and
and that's what uh gets you to that
place and then uh
hopefully you just do it right and and
then we got to that hallway there's just
certain things that came out of my body
i just never heard before so
that's like as i said uh i've never lost
anyone yet with that kind of impact
so that's why it's a all new all-new
territory for me
yeah you're great in that in that scene
and uh and like i said before you guys
are great together
um i gotta wrap uh thank you both so
much for talking with me
and i'm just gonna say i cannot [ __ ]
wait for dune that's it
guess what guess what i'm gonna go to it
right after this